so I actually asked David what should I
do when things get tough haha this is a
good [ __ ] question manikin is going to
get [ __ ] difficult day after day
after day that's the thing about what
you're doing right now that's that's
challenging is a lot of the
[ __ ] can sign up for the
[ __ ] one-day event why don't we do a
lot of these CEOs a lot of these people
don't want to suffer you know as a
living who don't want to suffer as
making it a habit what they do is they
go out and they recruit these people to
put them through a two day three day
[ __ ] challenge anybody can do that
[ __ ] because your mind can process two
or three [ __ ] days of suck what
you're doing my friend is going to be
damn near a month of suck so basically
you're gonna have a lot of days
especially in the morning time the
mornings when you wake up and your body
says go [ __ ] yourself because I don't
[ __ ] like doing this today and you're
gonna look at cuz you're running six
miles a day I believe what you know
what's going to happen to your [ __ ]
ass you're gonna wake up in the morning
and you're gonna [ __ ] do what I do
people think all David goggies just
wakes the [ __ ] up and he just gets just
[ __ ] on he gets this [ __ ] am I gonna I
don't get up and get after it I look at
my shoes sometimes for hours I pass them
I go I get stuff to drink I go to the
bathroom I watch TV I'll start doing
some work and I look at those [ __ ]
shoes because why my body's saying go
[ __ ] yourself so you have to be able to
win the morning you have to be able to
not allow that to get too deep in your
brain and when things get really tough
for you when you're out there on like
day 17 and your knees are hurting and
your back is hurt and your shoulders are
hurting your elbow get elbow tendonitis
and all kind of [ __ ] going on you got to
start remembering your resume a lot of
people don't remember what the [ __ ]
they've accomplished in life and at that
time of suffering you have to be able to
[ __ ] go
through and pull up that [ __ ] who the
[ __ ] I am resume and say Oh for you you
I'm sure you studied your [ __ ] ass
off for hours and days and years to give
her your ass I guarantee you did [ __ ]
harder than this
and that's basically what you have to go
back to but it's hard to do because in
that moment of suffering all you can
[ __ ] think about is getting the [ __ ]
out of it so you got take that one
second to pull yourself out of that
suffering to have a clear [ __ ]
thought it's hard to have clear thoughts
in the midst of extreme pain and
suffering find that clear thought remind
yourself of what you've been through
back in the past back in the day to get
to where you're at today so that's what
I do it's a constant reminder and then
through that process I guarantee you
your mind and body muster up we got this
we we've been here before maybe not that
kind of pain and suffering but we've
been here before in the demons of your
own mind so that's the best reminder in
the world
you